And now it's the old scout master.
This is why you should go out in the wilderness.
You are who you are out there.
You cannot fake your character.
There's no facade,
And I love that, especially when you go out as a group,
especially with the scouts.
they'll be friends with those kids for life. for that,
because of that trip,
because they went through all that,
especially on a winter trip.
Imagine that
They go off into the wilderness, into a snowstorm.
It's minus 20..
They're warm all the time,
but they come back and tell everybody how miserable it was,
what it really wasn't,
and reconnect with themselves and reconnect with nature,
And I think that's what's all about.
If you've listened to the podcast for a while,
you recognize that voice.
That is our friend from Canada,
Kevin Callan, the happy camper.
He's got a great new book.
I can hardly wait to have him tell you all about it.
This is podcast number 357..
Hey,
Oh
Hey.
Joining me today on the Scoutmaster Podcast
is author Kevin Callan
And if you've been listening to the podcast for a while,
you've heard Kevin on the podcast before
one of my favorite authors. He's up there in the wild North
country of Canada and Kevin has written the complete guide to
winter camping and I don't know that I've ever seen a book
exactly like it. It's really wonderful and I'm glad to have
you back, Kevin, Hello, Hello, Are you up there? I am
Far, far north of Ridge North. you know, Nobody's done this
book before. Derek Conover actually did a really good
job with Snow Walker. I would say that's the Bible.
Him and Caltham's Paradise, Blue Zero, are the two main books.
Garrett wrote the core to my book, which was a huge honor. Yeah,
Yeah, It's only been out. now for how long? Just like two weeks,
Two weeks. Yeah, Yesterday I was at the
winter camping symposium in Kitchener, Marleau in Ontario,
and it was sold out. It was 300 people and I had a sold
100, 150 books. Wow, It scared the living day like that
I really did. I was nervous. I was signing books and I was
actually shaking while signing, Because now you're an
expert or something. No, I'm not really the expert in
winter camping. I love winter camping. I love
hot-tenting. In fact, I think sometimes I can't
more than the winter time they do in the summer.
I know a lot of people that know more about it than I
do. I went out and reached out to them. The book has all
these sidebars and all these other information from
other people, Mm-hmm. And that's how the book was
born. It's sort of a collaboration of all our
minds together and all our ideas together, not just
this one individual Kind of reminded me of
Expedition Canoing. Looking over his book, I went:
wait a minute, he did that, Yeah. So yeah, exactly,
It works, and putting it all together in this context
really helps. There's a lot of very useful stuff.
What's the temperature got to be, to call it winter
camping? For me it's got to be colder than minus 10..
I'm talking Celsius. You need a really nice dry
cold. If it's a damp cold, it's just miserable
out, But if it's a nice minus 10,, minus 20,
it's amazing really. Whenever I've been out
in anything close to zero or below zero
in Fahrenheit, it's dry, the snow squeaks. people
look at it and they think, oh gosh, I would
never, ever go out when it's that cold. Well,
anything below freezing ain't so bad. which, in
Celsius, is zero, right? Yeah, That's true winter. I
mean what people really think of winter is to
go from their car to the shopping mall in a
damp, cold, sort of miserable day, when it's
kind of sleety, raining. Well, that's not winter
camping at all, Because when you go winter
camping it's good: minus 10,, minus 20 Celsius.
You get out of your car and you think you're
insane. You really do. I've done what many
people have never done this before. They
look at me like I do not want to do this
camping. We're going to go for how many
days in this environment? I would look.
you're not used to the environment. Once
you start hauling that freight to log in
or carrying that pack down the trail,
you're going to warm up. But what gets
cold is when you stop and then you
have to make camp. And if you do cold
camping and you do a four-season
tent, which is great, It's all right. If
you do a tarp or even a hammock, or
with a quilt underneath, or or you do a
Quincy or whatever, the only thing that's
going to get you warm is your own body
heat. So just imagine the beauty of it-
And again, it might be because I'm older
and wiser or whatever. but get a hot
tent with canvas, like a snow trucker
that's made in the United States, And you
get that thing set up. You get a wood
stove inside. It's a sauna inside. I
mean, you're sitting there with a
t-shirt on, Everybody's talking, We're
playing cards. We're making a good
meal in a Dutch oven. We're making a
curry or stew on the stove, We're
having some tea, enjoying ourselves.
We're not in the tent hoping the
morning is coming, Right, Yeah, And it's
almost like you're carrying your
log cabin with you. That's exactly
what it is. Everybody wants to have a
log cabin. Well, a prospector tent
with a wood stove inside, on a freight
log, and it's exactly the same thing,
except you can move it. So if we talk
somebody into this right and we say,
okay, winter camping is great and you
want to be out, You definitely want to
be out when it's below freezing, How are
you going to tell them to put together a
kit where they can go out and be
comfortable in that kind of weather
for a night or two? You can say to them:
you won't be cold, Bake, seal and borrow
before you go and buy stuff. I mean, a
sleeping bag for the winter is like
600 bucks. Who has 600 bucks per sleeping
bag? Yeah, So I would do a two
fall sleeping bags put together, or I
would rent a sleeping bag and put a
liner inside and for scouts. it's
amazing. There's a lot of things in here
that are. I like the way that it's put
together here, because it's not. I wrote
it for the general person to get them
to go winter camping, So I sort of
it was a shotgun effect. It's like:
here's all the information. You can do
this, You can do this, You can do this,
You can do this. Here's some problems
that may happen. They may happen. They
may happen. Here's some great meals
you can have. Here's some great
experiences you can have. This is
why I like winter. That's the whole
thing about too. So why do I like
winter? Well, first of all, as a
Canadian, it's our God-given right to
enjoy winter. You had better.
Oh, I know. And you're one more person. I
don't know how many radio interviews I
did last week- controlling all They're
like: are you insane? No, I'm Canadian.
I might as well enjoy what we have, and
I think winter is a fantastic time of
the season, especially in the wilderness.
It's very silent. You'll see more
wildlife, even though there's less
wildlife to see, but you'll see more
of it in the winter, Lying on the
ice at minus 30 and hearing or even
feeling the ice crack and grown
underneath you because it expands and
contracts underneath you while you're
watching the northern lands. That's a lot
better than watching Netflix reruns.
It's an amazing, amazing time to be
outside and it's a shame if you don't
do it. You really have to make yourself
get out and do it. If you do it and
it's minus 20, minus 30 and everybody's
at home wondering about you and I
guarantee you're not going to be cold.
But man, the bragging rights you got
when you get home, Oh, it's far beyond
anything. because you're going to get
home and they're: are you all right?
Yep, Oh, no, no, that's. when you get
home and they say, are you all right?
You say well, oh, just barely, just barely,
it was did fine. I think that's what
boys do most of the time when they
go home. I hear from their mothers
about all the horrible things that
happened that I had no idea. You know all
the horrible privations and how cold
they were and how miserable they were
as they were laughing and
cavorting through an entire weekend.
but that's another story. Well, there's
a photo in the book of a group of
scouts my buddy, Andy, and I came upon.
they had made a snow cape to stay in.
I've never seen the happiest kids ever
like they were at. and you know,
it's true what they say: a snow storm
looks terrible. when you're looking at
the window and you're wondering if you
should go to work and you wonder if you
should go on the road. when you're on a
winter camping trip and there's a snow
storm,
you're in absolute bliss. Yeah, it's
amazing because the snow is dry. if the
sun's out, it's great. if it's snowing,
it's great. if it's cloudy, it's great.
and there are some dangers to that.
like, going across the ice is dangerous.
so there's some dangers with that.
there's dangers with getting a snow
blind. yeah, you just wear goggles or
sunglasses. and, yeah, remember the great
glacier glasses. remember that in the
70s, Yes, Yeah, everybody had to have
glacier glasses. Now you just go to the
dollar store and you buy a pair of
cheap sunglasses. you're good, Yeah, but
the glacier glasses for the cool effect.
come on, you want to look cool. Well, you
know it's funny, I wear mucklucks and I
wear an interact. everybody's like, wow,
you really looked apart. and you know,
what do you really wear out there?
no, I wear that. Yeah, I mean, the common
thing that you hear down here when we
start talking about winter camping is:
cotton kills. but that's not
necessarily so, is it? It does. if it's,
it's again if it's against your body,
like blue jeans, if you do sweat, it will
soak up that sweat and then put it right
to your skin and you're going to get a
hypothermia. but if you layer in wool,
when the sweat goes on your body, it
actually escapes into the wool and then,
when it's cold enough, it will actually
crystallize on the outside of the
wool and you shake it off and you're
dropped. Now if you have a canvas
anorak, what all that is doing is
breaking the wind and your breathing
is through the canvas, so you're
basically you're not getting wet
underneath. Now I wore, uh, uh, uh, uh.
what's the really fancy jacket? uh,
like a puffy jacket? No, well, you wear
that, but no, the windshell. they uh,
Oh, Gore-Tex, Gore-Tex, yes, Yeah,
It's been a long day. you know, It's
okay, we're both past the 50 mark, we're
loud, But yeah, you wear the Gore-Tex.
you can spend 500 bucks on it if you
want. I just find it doesn't work as
well as that traditional system of
wool. and then the canvas anorak. Yeah,
no, I'm a big fan of wool. Even go to the
Army Surplus and actually find something
like that for for a few dollars. that's
far better than actually spending 500
bucks on a really good jacket. So you
can go to the Goodwill or the
Salvation Army Store and you can find,
like an old wool sweater, even even
wool dress pants that are heavy enough,
you know, for five or six bucks, and those
will change your life in the winter
time outside. I even went to the Army
Surplus a couple years ago and got what's
called neos. uh, they're pullover boots
that you pull over on your boots or
your mucklucks. Oh yeah, I was looking,
you know, as I was going through the
footwear thing, I said, oh, I can't
wait to tell Kevin about neos. and
then, oh, no, he already knows. Oh, great,
great, yeah, they're hard to find, though.
I actually, uh, learned about them
working on a movie set years ago, like
10 years ago, and we were outside in the
snow for weeks and everybody in the
crew had neos. No, I've been talking
about those for a long time. they're
great. Now you do look like Herman
Mosser when you're walking in. Oh,
absolutely, these are like guy uggs.
Yeah, Oh, no, no, they're far better than that.
We've got the women on the fashion, I'm
telling you.
So, wool over the polyprose, I would go.
wool instead of a fleece, I would go
mucklucks with the neos more than I
would. just a good winter boot? Well, the,
those are like the pack boots, Yeah. so
don't buy boots that don't have liners.
We get below a certain temperature,
propane stoves not going to work
anymore. and then there's, um, the
kili kettle. Oh, the kili kettle, The kili kettle.
Here's to the kili kettle. Oh, here she is,
doesn't she? Will you never be firing up
the kili kettle? I love that thing. you
know, I I learned about the kili kettle
years ago when I was on a trip in Scotland
with my daughter and the outfitter
dropped us off and then I opened up
the kit that he gave me and there was
no stove except this kili kettle. it's
a sick stove, but I knew nothing about,
even about stick stoves at the time.
but but there we would gather the,
the sticks and burn them and that's what
you would use, and I thought this is
really cool. So then I bought one. when I
got back the idea of having a boil up
did I should stop during the day
and make a cup of tea, and I think my
introduction of the book tells a
really good story. with that, I was
traveling with Charlie, this native
Cree elder, up in Northern Quebec for a
month and he taught me how to live
with the land as opposed to try to
to survive it. and I was only maybe
five, six days into the month and I was
hungry and there was a snowshoe here in
front of me, so I shot it and I missed
and I ran after it and he goes: oh you're
silly white man, and I am a really
silly hyper white man, I really am.
so he's right with that characterization.
and so he said: let's just have a boil
up. I went: oh, come on, Charlie, now I
really respected the man. I didn't
really know him that well, but I
respected him. so I did what he
wanted and it was minus 42 celsius,
right, yeah, so do a boil up. you have
to chisel through the ice because you
don't drink snow up there, because that's
just wrong. now that would take about
40 minutes minimum to chisel through
the ice to get water. so I got water,
got the fire going, got some spruce
boughs to sit on, got the tea going.
you know, I was just about to put the
fire out. he was: well, let's have lunch,
Kevin. I went, what do you mean?
see the rabbit, the snowshoe hare, goes on
its own run in the winter time,
so traveled back by that point. I killed
the rabbit, we ate it, and I wasn't
silly white man anymore. okay, so tell me
about the tea, because you talk about
some teas in here. you got white pine
tea. yeah, white pine tea, spruce tea- I
prefer black spruce tea. laboratory tea
is good because that those leaves are
still going to be there in the winter
time. you take a bundle of white pine
needles and you throw them in water and
you get a tea. yeah, I've never tried
that. oh, it's good. wow, I put a bit of
brown sugar in. I would say that
black spruce actually gives you a bit of
a kick. now, if you find yellow birch,
oh, it tastes of wintergreen. if you get
a bunch of yellow birch twigs and throw
that in and boil it up,
whoa, it's amazing. I am gonna have to try
that. I'm looking forward to it. I'm gonna
take the Kelly kettle out and we'll
find us a white pine and have a bit of tea.
going off into Ontario and have in the
Canada and having a Kelly kettle with
some some yellow birch twigs with
a bit of scotch in it. oh lord,
that's like it's really good. I think in
one sense because you're stopping and
you're taking what you have around you
in your environment, but also you're
stopping and getting warm liquid in you
and, I suppose, to again surviving. you're
actually replenishing your resources and
rethinking what, what you're- I don't be
in a hurry out there, I don't be in a
hurry at all. have lots of tea,
have lots of boil ups, and
you're not out to try and make miles.
you're not. yeah, I mean it's not, it's not
for bragging rights. I did 75 miles in
three days, or kilometers.
you're not out to make kilometers. it
doesn't work here. though, when you get
pulled over, a speeding, if you say
I'm sorry, I'm American, I didn't
understand. they still give you.
I haven't had the pleasure yet yet.
where's a piece of wood? not gonna?
yeah, all I have is like a three
season
regular old two, three-man tent,
and I want to take it out in the
winter. what do I do?
how do I make myself comfortable? if you
only have a three season, that's fine,
and where you are in more southern,
you're gonna be fine as well.
the big thing about the tent- a cold
tent- is ventilation. so there's the
fly over the tent, there's a body of
the tent and there's a fly over the
tent. the body of the tent should
actually have a lot of mesh in it,
because you're in your sleeping bag
and you're breathing out
all that. that air coming out of
your mouth is going up
up top and if they can't escape
it's actually going to collect onto
the walls as crystals
and then you get really warm in there.
because it will get warm, it will fall
down like raining on you
and it'll get everything wet.
I'm good with my three season 10, as
long as we're not going to get a whole
bunch of snow dumped, dumped on us,
yeah, and I'm getting ready to get
into bed and crawl into my sleeping
bag.
but, especially if I'm talking to
scouts or I'm talking to people
who aren't very experienced with
winter camping,
what's the, what's the regimen
for going to sleep?
make sure that your sleeping bag
is a good sleeping bag and if you
don't have a good one, make use
two or three of them layered.
also, what's underneath you is
important, because you're sleeping on
the snow and everybody's freaking out
about sleeping on the snow or the
or the cold ground.
you're better off if there is snow.
snow is insulation,
so it's going to be warmer,
but your body is going to melt that
snow and you're going to
melt into it and then you're going
to get cold because of that.
so make sure you have a good
thermo rest underneath you
now, if you don't have a good
thermo rest,
get a cheap thermo rest.
go to the hardware store
and get the pipe insulation
and cut a six foot length of that
and that will actually go
underneath you
and that will actually
reflect heat underneath you,
and then you'll get that for six bucks-
a little bit of extra insulation
on the underneath,
and then, whatever I've been
wearing during the day,
I want to get out of that.
yeah, you do,
because you sweat it in that,
even though you're not
supposed to sweat,
you are going to sweat.
so then, therefore,
you want to get the
clammy gear off you
and then put
fresh stuff on,
and you're not going to
want to do that.
yeah, you're going to.
I always wear
a brand new pair of socks,
a brand new
marina wool sweater.
I wear a toke-
a toke.
what? what the heck is that?
what's wrong with you down there?
you've never worn a toke before.
oh, of course, I've worn many a toke.
I always wear a toke.
eh,
eh.
yeah, a hat,
and I wear a wool hat.
don't cover your face
in your sleeping bag,
because if you do,
your breath is going to go
in the sleeping bag
and climb it all up.
I think it's really good
is how you get out.
the outdoor store
is a SOL
bivvy.
it's just one of those
reflector blankets
that you put in
your sleeping bag
or over your sleeping bag
and that's going to give you
another 10 degrees warmer.
it's a good thing
to carry along
a second pair of thermals
and, like you said,
a nice dry pair of socks
and you can leave them
right in the sleeping bag.
actually,
I do. yeah,
my big woolies
I put in there.
and, uh,
what's more important
is the pillow
I got on sale the other day.
so the pillow
that he is showing me right now-
because I have the benefit
of being able to see
all of this live-
is a glorious,
sequined snowman pillow
and you should just
see the light on it.
yes, it's the
the best pillow
I've ever seen in my life.
it's like
getting a Christmas sweater,
uh.
so what happened was
I saw this pillow
and, uh,
my daughter goes
is the ugliest pillow
I've ever seen in my life, dad.
that's why I bought it
and absolutely,
you have to buy it then,
so it actually cost me 45 dollars.
that's a lot of sequins.
I've never spent that much money
on a pillow before my.
sometimes a man's got to do
what a man's got to do. Kevin,
that's right.
yeah,
you like that pillow,
you buy that pillow.
that's gotta be.
I want to see that
in a video in a hot tent.
oh, I know that
I said that's what I thought.
my next, uh,
my next uh,
winter trip,
uh,
I'm gonna go in a couple
weeks actually,
with my buddy Andy.
I'm bringing that pillow.
it's not a comfortable pillow
but it's tacky,
so
it's absolutely a must.
it's a key piece of gear.
Kevin, thanks so much
for joining us again.
it's always great to talk to. you
love the book
and I think a lot of people
are gonna like it.
you say it's doing pretty well.
huh,
it is Clarke.
I was actually, um,
I was a little nervous. uh,
you know,
we guess it's a.
it's a book on winter camping.
you would think.
who goes winter camping?
just,
it's insane, right?
I think people
in general,
more and more people,
want to get out there
in the wilderness.
there's so much stuff
going on in life
that
the only time that
that gives you sort of
solace
is to be out in the woods
and winter time
is a long time
just to sit there
and not do anything.
so I
I just really found winter
camping to be
on the rise
and, uh,
I guess I've proven it
because it's just selling
like crazy.
it's a great book
and, once again,
thanks so much
for joining us.
thank you,
and uh,
and make sure you keep
getting those kids out there,
because if they,
if the kids don't go out
there,
we're all going to die
in a terrible
zombie apocalypse,
apocalypse
something like that,
even in Canada.
thanks so much for listening
to this edition
of the scout master podcast.
if you go,
and uh,
you look at the post
that contains this podcast,
you'll find a number of notes
about the gear
and the books
Kevin and I mentioned
during our conversation,
just in case you're interested
in following up on them.
if you'd like to get in touch
with me,
I'm always available at Clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
that's C-L-A-R-K-E
I want to take a moment
to thank all the backers
and the patrons
who make this possible.
you can find out
how you can join them
by going to scoutmastercgcom.
look for the support link
right at the top of the page.
all the remains for us to do today
is to hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you
and good camping.
why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.